yes Bella has just joined us in the
studio congratulations Bella once again
I wanted to tell you we love you you
don't have to win all these days you can
stay
so how does it feel like you want the
fourth game
yeah I'm surprised myself but it feels
really good I'm delighted that I could
manage uh one four games in a row
Bella was it the bluff
I thought that it was interesting during
the game so but you didn't prepare this
before you did no I I wasn't prepared
against this variation so okay yes it
was an interesting variation but what if
9490 suggested this move uh take Knight
takes it from Queen Seven
yeah I was thinking something like this
we just be shocked me too and Castle
here then or first night F6 95
through this possibility or not now F6
is coming yes there is a F6 as well so
me I think maybe one of the moves here
was also Bishop G5
that's something something should be
okay so let's have a look at the game
but here you have a clear Advantage yeah
here I was thinking about 94
problem it should be better Bishop D3
and F5 but I think after he takes F6 it
should be better anyway Knight of
success so she chose this plan to
transfer at least 926
there's a very interesting maneuvering
game yeah
so we we didn't understand what was
going on so I wanted to play Knight G3
Knight F5 at some point about here so
somehow I did not
you didn't manage yes but did you
consider the long Castle also at some
point or not at all you were always yeah
Castle in short here okay so just
instead of H5 I was thinking maybe C5
I probably have to take and queen D1
frequency five nights
after B6 94 probably
I don't know
just a very nice position but maybe you
can Castle because here after visual
based six yes I think you have a very
comfortable Advantage here so
Elizabeth tried to stabilize the things
here with H5 a nice fingers
maybe Knight G5 was not the most precise
move maybe but I could not find any
better
so 95 and H4
and then here
to H3 yes there was
an interesting position
let's see here you played very well and
you took on C5 did you consider the move
native 3 and Knight H4 here yeah I did
but after 96 Knight H4 I don't know and
somehow I think that taking on C5 was
better
but decision here actually we thought
that there is a draw like after yes
because then instead of if you take on
C2 and check checks yes
how can you defend
because I want to bring my Rook
King V1 I'm probably
then yes then then the relation changes
completely after an ID for the computer
thinks that black is much better yes we
were thinking about King G2 but then
rugby8 and draw
I was thinking something like this but
oh that's just anyway that was a quite
complicated position in the time travel
and I think that your opponent missed G4
here yes
I don't know actually but I think after
Roxy tonight through King F3 she had a
chance 92 no
ah yes that was a very very interesting
moment so yes what did you what just
don't look here what did you want to
make here I don't know I was thinking
about this position for a long time and
um
I could not find a really good mom
the computer you know what is the winner
such as Rook H4 I think it's the only
movie yes but after Rook D3 King Kito
Rook E3 King D2 probably I think here
you have to play King F2
G6 I don't I don't know what what is
this
yes He suggests this just cooked
yesterday yes taking on B2 it's not
because yes the king is coming yes okay
yes and here with the king of five you
have G6 yes but okay it's nice
nevertheless yes it's a very complicated
position and here you're already
completely winning so you just have to
be precise
so let's have a winning position here
so Bella you're still in the race for
the first place in this tournament two
games left yeah
two games left
so we well we're looking
[Music]
um
seeing to seeing you in the studio boy
thank you I think they're scared now you
know when you enter the plane hole you
know they run away
thank you Bella Bella oh congratulations
but a very quick question for you what
is your best winning streak
do you win four games in a row five
games in a row actually I don't remember
so this might as well be your best
winning streak probably yeah since such
a strong tournament yes in such a strong
tournament probably wow very very good
luck indeed Bella you're thrilling is uh
with your victories and four in a row I
mean